i have to say i i feel that i'm ignorant
here but uh in iceland uh i don't know
much about what happens there except
i've heard there's a lot of drinking in
iceland which has always intrigued me is
that fair to say oh yes absolutely um
well what a lot of people don't really
know is that beer
a beer was actually outlawed until about
1990 which was when i was born why was
beer outlawed i don't understand why
that would be the case it's it's a
fairly innocuous alcoholic beverage
compared to others well not in the hands
of icelanders i can tell you that oh i
see okay all right so
they didn't want you guys so what did
you guys drink instead of beer well the
thing is the stronger the spirits and
the clear liquids those were all still
um
you could you could buy those they were
just so expensive that the uh the quote
unquote common man couldn't really
afford them
oh
um so essentially i think it goes that
the the logic goes that the you know the
rich and the powerful they wanted to
keep drinking whereas it was seen as a
bit um
gauche for the the commoners to be
drinking so they just outlawed beer what
terrible terrible leadership you had
it's completely missing the point
of what it means to be alive so
uh what tell me what are these spirits
so what are you drinking i'll tell you
this i've been to many years ago i went
to finland and i have a very
strong bond with the people of finland
and everywhere i went they offered me
korskinkova
and koroskinkova
did taste like something you would put
in a mig fighter to make it go faster uh
it it it was a powerful
powerful powerful alcohol do you have
anything like korskankova
uh in in iceland what do you have
absolutely we've got something called
brendevin
yes it's essentially burnt wine
and it tastes like
oh tastes like gasoline it just clears
you right up if you're feeling a bit
stuffed just a drip of it will clear it
all up so is it technically a wine that
someone just put on the stove and burned
yeah i believe so a lot of our sort of
most traditional drinks and foods are
sort of discovered by accident it feels
like
like iceland exactly
right iceland itself was a total totally
founded accidentally and uh and you have
the same thing with all of your foods so
your drink is burnt wine
and then your your what is your favorite
deal like some turkey that fell on the
floor
a pie that fell off a shelf and smashed
is your national dish yeah it's on the
flag actually
um but no the um i can tell you that
probably you won't get any more
traditional icelandic than uh burnt wine
and then fermented shark oh right i've
heard about this i did hear about this
in iceland you you eat fermented sharks
so what's that all about because
i'm trying to use find the right word
stupid there you go oh yeah that sounds
stupid to ferment a shark i mean
literally let a shark rot and then start
gnawing away at it oh yeah even better
we actually bury it in the ground and
let it rot then we dig it back up and
eat it for some unknown reason again
this was an accident someone
someone said well let's just bury this
shark we've got plenty of food then
realize later actually we don't where
did i leave that shark
well i think you buried him over there
hey let's dig them up wow pretty rancid
let's start to chompin
so anyway i shouldn't have said stupid
that was uh culturally uh
ignorant of me but also very honest
you're eating a rotten shark right yeah
there's really no defending it really
and you wash it down with burnt wine oh
yeah just to really drive home the
self-hatred for sure